[Music]
dan's in hartford connecticut dan
welcome to the ramsey show what's up
hey guys how you doing thank you for
taking my call sure
um big fan of you dave i've read uh two
of your books financial piece and tony
uh total money makeover i'm on um entre
leadership right now about halfway
through wow i'm um self-employed myself
um
and uh i got a quick question for you in
being self-employed and you know i make
contributions to my roth into myself
every month
um i know natchez one of the biggest
things i think a lot of people fear is
the market constantly going up and down
up and down and i've gotten to i think
the bad habit of checking
my profile uh portfolio every morning
okay and i kind of wanted to kind of get
your
um
take any tips or feedback on having the
minds of just
um not focusing on that as much every
day and kind of just taking a step back
from it's one of the hardest challenges
i have
as a business owner as a as a person
um
only that i have right now is my
mortgage um but i wanted but the market
is constantly as you guys know going up
and down it's and it's kind of created a
sense of
uneasiness for me i just want to kind of
get your take on
my mindset on how to be okay with that
that's a really good question i like
that question
i think a lot of people struggle with
this i
i kind of went through the same thing in
a different area uh when the book entre
leadership came out years ago is when i
got on twitter
twitter was fairly new
and i jumped on twitter was fun in those
days
we would just spar back and forth we'd
have some fun i mean occasionally you
get a troll and we just block them or
first we make fun of them and then we
block them uh but you know i mean we had
a lot of fun with it but but twitter
over the years has just deteriorated and
it's basically a septic tank now
i mean it's a disaster and so but i got
in the habit in those days of checking
twitter uh my tweet deck with all ever
all mentions of dave ramsey i would
check it every morning while i was
drinking coffee
and you know when it wasn't bad that
wasn't bad
but when it was bad i had to quit i had
to i didn't take it off my computer i
don't even look at twitter anymore
because it's just it's all nastiness i
don't read i don't read crap every day
and expect my brain to be good
that's one example that comes to mind
second example comes to mind is
um
i uh about three and a half years ago i
decided my wife decided i was gonna
learn how to play golf and now i'm i'm
kind of into it
and i suck
um
and so the uh i have figured out the
secret to golf though the secret to
happiness is low expectations
now
so
the uh
if you don't expect much then it ain't
bad you know so i'm not all torqued out
about it and in that case let's let's
modify that a little bit for your
situation and call it this yeah your
expectation is not to get rich every
morning your expectation is to ride this
investment for 10 or 20 years correct
right right so quit using a tool that
doesn't match your expectation
your tool if you're checking it every
morning as if you're a freaking day
trader
and you're not a doctor yeah you're not
a day trader right you're a long-term
investor so quit checking it every
morning because you're you're you're
okay the methodology you're using
doesn't match with
your goal
okay
i love the golf analogy i gotta jump on
this dan he took us there let me tell
you first of all yeah he doesn't suck
and he's not kind of into it he's
obsessed as any golfer really is when he
when he puts the time into it so i'm
gonna stay with this this analogy
so for the golfer and i'm now getting to
where dave was about two years ago and i
played yesterday
yeah i practiced for an hour and a half
and then i went and played by myself and
here's what i know when i have a bad
hole dan
i forget it it's the next tee box you
gotta forget it and move on any golfer
will tell you that and the goal for me
is not to have a great round yesterday
because that's not realistic
expectations as dave said the goal for
me is to be able to play i'm 47. i want
to play when i'm 67
77 and i want to be better so this is a
long-term deal and investing as well as
getting good at anything or mastering
anything um you have to have the long
view not the short view and the emotions
are tied to
the temporary yeah you're putting trash
in your brain
because you're you're you're reading
these things i don't look at mine every
morning
because i don't have an expectation of
what it's going to do today i couldn't
care less what's going to do all i care
about it does over five years
what it does over 10 years
i mean i wonder about the market
occasionally because a bunch of you
people bring it up but
um but generally speaking i'm
betting that the u.s economy and the
best and brightest companies in the u.s
are going to be worth more 20 years from
today than they are now by the way
there's a track record based on that too
i mean it's 100 yeah 100 of the time but
if you leave it alone 20 years you made
money
in the stock market's history there's no
20-year period of time ever including
the great depression including
0.809.07 whatever it was and included
you know you can look at any consecutive
20-year period of time 100 of them made
money and all you're saying is is home
depot dell
apple
mcdonald's and coca-cola and so on are
going to as a group be worth more 20
years from now than they are today are
they going to be worth more in the
morning i don't know what finland is
going to do that's going to affect the
economy this morning nothing i well they
might have
i just don't know and i don't care
because i'm thinking long term and so
down that you get your if you're going
to think long term use a reporting
system that is looking out long term
don't use a reporting system that's
every morning you're driving yourself
nuts
take that off take that little button
off your computer it's right up there in
your task bar and your favorites go in
there right now and click remove
click delete
where it's harder to go i don't have my
mutual funds in my taskbar
they're not in my they're not in my
favorites
and neither is twitter by the way
the golf channel might be no i'm kidding
this is the ramsey show